-Now, Ashton, you play
a ranch hand on your show,
so we wanted to put
your farm skills to the test
with a good old-fashioned
cow-milking contest.
You in?
-Yeah, I'm in.
But it's -- We raise, like
beef cows on the show,
so you don't really, like,
milk a beef cow.
It's not --
-Yeah, well, these are --
These are milking cows. We -
-These are Holstein cows.
These are dairy cows.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, whatever.
I mean, there's another season
You could do it next year.
You could be --
-No! They don't --
The beef cows
and the dairy cows are --
-This will be fun.
So, yes, you're in.
All right. Here's how
this is going to work.
You and I will each
have to milk our cows
as the timer counts down.
Whoever has the most milk
when time runs out wins.
-I don't know how to milk a cow!
-The loser --
You think I do? Come on.
Loser has to personally go u
to everyone in the audienc
and say, "I'm sorry
I didn't milk the cow better."
-No. This is a --
-That's what you have to do.
-I'm from Iowa.
-Yeah, you're from Iowa.
You should be used to this
Take our positions here.
Take -- You got that cow.
I have this cow over here.
-Dairy cows are from,
like, Wisconsin.
I don't even know what this is
Like --
-Wow. This is kind of amazing.
-M-M-M-Milk!
-Wow.
-Okay. Hey, girl. Hi.
-Oh, my God.
I can't see you, Ashton, but -
-We're gonna get real clos
to one another.
-Okay.
-Are you prepared?
When do -- How do we know
when to start? What do we do
-I don't know
which one you grab.
I got four of them on my side.
-Yours is a female.
Did you get the male
or the female, Jimmy?
-[ Laughs ]
I think I got four males.
Uh.
-Okay.
-All right. Here we go.
Oh, you're warming up
your hands. You're cheating.
-Well, I don't want her
to get shocked.
-All right. Here we go.
-Easy, girl. Easy, girl.
-All right. Ready?
-Whoa, whoa. My cow's moving
-Are you ready?
-No, I'm not ready. My cow's -
Oh, my God. He pooped.
Hold on. My cow just
dropped a deuce, dude.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
It's okay, girl. It's okay
Hold on. Jimmy. Jimmy.
Jimmy, it's starting.
Get behind yours.
-No, I can't.
-No, no. It's a go. We're going.
-No, I can't go over there
I can't go over there.
-This I'm used to. I'm used to
being around cow poop.
-Oh, my gosh.
-I'm fine with this.
It's the milking I don't know.
But we'll -- I'll manage.
-All right.
-I mean, it's loose, too, bud.
She's nervous.
New York City?!
Okay. I'm good. I'm good.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Coughing ]
I can't do it.
-You can do it!
-Jim. Come on, bud.
-Are you going to do it?
-Last time I was here, you mad
me eat a bunch of weird stuff.
Now you got to stand
and milk by poop.
-All right.
What's got to go out?
Are you going to do it?
-I'm going to do it.
She just dropped a deuce.
We're fine.
-All right. Good.
Oh, my God. Okay. Oh, my God
-We got this.
-All right. Here we go.
-You ready? Hold your breath
-I can't even look.
On your mark.
-Oh, God. I'm right in it.
-[ Coughing ] God.
I have a very weak stomach
I have a weak stomach.
This is going to be --
All right. Crazy. Ready?
On your mark. Oh, my God.
I think I'm -- [ Coughs ]
-Say, "Go."
-[ Coughs ]
-Say, "Go," Jimmy!
[ Laughter ]
Jimmy, I can only hold my breath
for so long.
-I can't do it.
-I'm holding cow teats!
Let's go!
-I don't think I can do it
I can't do it.
-Start the thing, Jimmy!
-All right.
All right. Here we go.
-Do I win by default?
-All right. Here we go. Ready?
On your mark, get set, go.
-Are you not even milking?
-I'm going.
I swear to God I'm doing it.
Here we go.
-I'm getting nothing.
She's dried up.
I got a dry heifer.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Oh, oh, there's some milk
Yeah, come on, girl.
Oh, there we go. That's a shot
Breakfast!
-She's milking herself.
-Does anybody have any Cheerios?
-I can't even look down. I don't
even know what's going on.
-Oh, yeah, oh, yeah. You got i
real bad over there, bud.
I'm right in the middle
of the deuce zone.
Just like --
-Oh, my gosh.
[ Buzzer ]
-All right. Buzzer's --
All right. Stop.
-Wow. Cool. Okay. All right.
-My cow's still going.
It's kind of awesome.
-What?!
-Are you ready? Are you ready?
-Yeah, I'm ready.
-All right. Good.
Let's get away from there.
-I got, like, a dribble.
-Oh, my gosh.
That was one of
the most insane things
I've ever had to sit next to
I was --
I don't know how you did that.
But I still can't breathe.
-It's the mustache.
[ Laughter ]
You have no idea
what this thing smells like.
-All right.
Let's see how we did.
-Oh, you're --
you're crushing me at --
-Ready?
-All right, yeah, let's see.
[ Laughter ]
-That's what you did?
[ Applause ]
-I was working over there.
I think I got more on my han
than I got in the jar.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's how you milk a cow
right there. Sorry, Ashton
-Sorry. I don't know
how to milk a cow.
-No, you have to apologize t
every person in the audience
"I'm sorry I didn't
milk the cow better"
is exactly what you have to say.
Ashton Kutcher right there
Thank you for being here, buddy.
I was just kidding.
I can't believe that.
I can't believe --
Oh, I didn't do that.
-Your idea.
-"The Ranch" is back
with new episodes
on Netflix this Friday.
Stick around.
We'll be right back
with Billie Lourd, everybody
-Sorry I didn't
milk the cow better.
-It's okay. It's all right
-I'm sorry I didn't
milk the cow better.
-Next time.
-Get 'em next time.
-Sorry I didn't
milk the cow better.